I just sat down and realized that I have
to sum up the plot of this movie in this
review I have no idea how I'm going to
do that
Winter's Tale stars Colin Farrell and
Russell Crowe and what this movie is
about is a man and there's a love story
there are dark angels and good angels is
a flying horse there's a woman who sees
light in everything and a guy who lives
for like 150 years and it comes out on
Valentine's Day so take your
girlfriend's take your boyfriend's do
your thing seriously though all jokes
aside this is one of the most original
movies I've ever seen sometimes that's a
good thing sometimes that's a bad thing
essentially what this movie is about is
a romance Colin Farrell meets this woman
who's very very sick there's a fantasy
element to it where Russell Crowe's
character used to work with him he's
clearly some sort of a dark angel who is
after him and I can't really explain
much else of the plot without spoiling
things but it is a very original movie
and sometimes that is a very good thing
during this film there are times this
movie where I had no idea where it was
going it was very difficult to predict
and that is definitely a plus it's also
a very good-looking movie it's a well
shot it's well made it looks very nice
the cinematography is gorgeous some of
the special effects could have been a
little bit better I enjoyed watching
this movie purely because of how
different it was and how original it was
and the performances were fantastic
Colin Farrell was very good in this
movie Russell Crowe was really hamming
it up as this evil character but I
enjoyed his performance because he was
clearly having a ball being super cheesy
into the role really chewing up the
scenery there was also a very unexpected
cameo that I will not spoil that I think
was pretty cool and added to the film
and it was a plus for the movie but
there are some problems with this movie
and namely the fact that it tries to
balance so many different types of a
movie all in one as I said it's very
difficult to sum up the plot for this
movie it's so many different movies all
meshed into one it's a horror film
it's a fantasy film it's a romance it's
a comedy it's all of these things into
one that's kind of cool it's original
it's different but because of that the
tone shifts so often and so abruptly and
the story and the way it's told isn't
told as clearly as it should be so some
people who may not be as invested in the
book the source material
may have a hard time grasping this movie
also some aspects of it weren't really
as filled with awe or wonderment as it
should have been and it was more sort of
like well that's a really pretty shot
but it didn't really get me into the
moment like it should have even though
it was trying to go for a very
fantastical element that's really
supposed to uplift you and make you care
I cared about the characters I was
interested in where they were going and
the story intrigued me but I wasn't as
filled with as much in throw mentality
like this it's just that the script
itself felt kind of weak for this huge
epic story they were trying to tell
nevertheless I was interested in where
the story was going there were certain
elements of it that were cheesy and were
over-the-top but I admired the film for
trying to do something different for
that reason I'm going to give it a
b-minus I wouldn't necessarily recommend
seeing this in theaters I do admire the
effort they put forth in this movie
trying to do something very different I
know that Martin Scorsese at one point
in time was thinking of making this
movie but he deemed the book unfilmable
and I can see why because it's kind of
hard to describe this movie honestly so
guys if you have seen the movie or if
you have read the book I'm curious to
know what your thoughts are the
comparisons the differences if you think
that the movie was able to live up to
what was in the book I'm very curious to
know what you think as always guys
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
Oh